it took Karen Thomas three grueling
weeks and a lifetime of hard work to win
the Tour de France in a few seconds an
opportunist thief stole his glittering
prize Team Sky had loaned the coop Omni
Spore to bike maker Pinarello for the
cycle show in Birmingham organizers say
it had been momentarily left unattended
during the clear up afterwards Pinarello
say they accept full responsibility and
have personally apologized to Thomas in
a statement the Welsh cyclist said it is
incredibly unfortunate that this has
happened it goes without saying that the
trophy is of pretty limited value to
whoever took it but means a lot to me
and to the team hopefully whoever took
it will have the good grace to return us
this isn't the first time a major
sporting trophy has been stolen famously
before the 1966 World Cup in England the
Jules Rimet trophy went missing only to
be found by pickles the dog and it's not
just sporting memorabilia that attracts
thieves
this man is due to stand trial accused
of stealing Frances McDormand Oscar for
Best Actress at an after-party in Los
Angeles in March so why would anyone
want to take something that will be so
difficult to sell on it is quite
recognizable and certainly within the
sort of cycling world and so you
wouldn't be able to tell very many
people about it you certainly wouldn't
be able to have it on you on your
mantelpiece and sort of brag about it
but then again we know that there are
people that's still very very famous
artworks or have very famous artwork
stolen to order and just knowing they've
got them even if they've got to keep
them locked away somewhere that's enough
for some people Karen Thomas has urged
the thief to do the right thing and hand
it back he says no matter what happens
now nobody can ever take away the memory
of actually winning the Tour de France
and de Brady Sky News